[Music]
glass is packed with a couple of neat
twists and turns that paint out a world
that reaches far beyond our three main
characters one of the most interesting
of those being dr. le staple played by
Sarah paulsen throughout this video I'll
be discussing dr. staple and tear ties
into the bigger law in full detail there
will be heavy spoilers here so if you
don't want to know anything about the
film or its ending and I highly suggest
that you turn off now but for everyone
else
I'm definition and welcome to the
channel where I roon it so you don't
have to one of the biggest twists in
glass comes when we learn that dr.
staple is in fact working for an agency
that eradicate spheal with superhuman
abilities it doesn't matter whether the
individual is using their powers for
good or bad the secret society still
wants to get rid of them
however dr. le staple is given leeway to
attempt a new tactic which is to
psychosomatically convinced the
super-powered beings that they are in
fact normal this is because the power of
belief is what manifested their
abilities in the first place
when David Dunn was drowning as a child
he wished that he could become
invincible which caused his powers to
come to fruition similar to this Kevin
used to believe he was an animal in
order to survive his mother's beatings
as a child this is why he became
obsessed with them and eventually turned
into the Beast
throughout split it's clear that the
character has a love for animals due to
the facts he comes out with in regards
to them and his occupation within the
zoo staple believes that by making them
believe they are normal that it will
reverse the process and the killings
will not have to be carried out the
agency themselves to believe that they
are the good guys and that by keeping
humanity at a level playing field that
they will not ultimately be destroyed by
those with superhuman abilities this is
because they are futurists similar to
Tony Stark in civil war they are trying
to navigate the best course of action in
order to make it so that superhumans do
not get to the point
that they are able to harm the normal
population we learn that in the past
there have been several occurrences of
this and every time that a villain or
hero rises that their opposition at two
rises to meet them this is similar to
the case of glass and David who are both
at opposite ends of the spectrum and you
could take from the film that they worry
with the Beast now on the rampage that
his opposite will rise to whilst
initially I did have a lot of problems
with this element when watching the
movie the more I've thought about it the
more I've realized it's actually okay
perhaps the world does need this in
place to stop it spiraling out of
control like the heroes in the MCU who
themselves found out that the law isn't
so forgiving
obviously I'd love to hear your thoughts
on the film and if you enjoy this reveal
if you learned something from this video
then please like it and check out my
breakdown of the film's full ending
which will be linked at the end this is
a channel for people who are super into
superheroes so if that's the kind of
thing you like hit subscribe thanks
again for taking the time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best I'll see you next time take care
peace
[Music]
[Music]